so hello welcome to my talk uh now we
are going to talk about uh making apps
that uh users
love but uh not only that but because
it's hard enough to make uh one app that
users love but uh what we are trying to
do is uh not only to do that for one
team but to do it for to help dozens of
teams at the same time do it so this
will be a story of uh the tools that or
some of the tools that we are using at
Upsilon to to address this
problem but before we talk about uh what
we do want to achieve let's talk a
little bit about what we want to avoid
so welcome to the application
graveyard uh this is a place where
applications go where they are not quite
what we set out to achieve so for
example uh some apps strictly speaking
satisfy requirements but perhaps then no
one ends up using them um perhaps uh
they are just too hard to use maybe they
are too slow they are full of technical
jargon or have some other deficiencies
that that make them hard to use uh that
can easily kill an up and finally maybe
the up is just
ugly so
uh I don't know about so we I I'm not
ashamed to admit that from time to time
uh one of our apps can can reach the um
or get close to the application
graveyard hopefully it can be rescued
from there and I wonder like what's your
experience so who put your hand up if
you have seen an app that was in the
application
graveyard yeah a lot of you so so
hopefully this talk can help you to
avoid it in the future so that's what we
want to do we want to escape the
application
graveyard okay so first of all like of
course we are going to try to do it
through great design but uh we don't
only care about design for its own sake
of course we care about it because great
design is a path to what we really want
which is adoption people using our apps
and impact that their lives are better
and the results of their their companies
are better as a result um and of course
the opposite is also true that if we
ignore design and we by accident end up
with a bad design this can be a
significant uh obstacle to adoption and
impact so that's what we would like to
avoid so a few words about me my name is
m parkaa I'm a manager at Upsilon and I
manage our design team and the design
tools one of which I will tell you about
in a second and uh so also in what I
wanted to share is that in my career uh
I I have learned two things that I
wanted to share today and that is that
design is not only about how things look
um and the second thing is that it's
very hard to to change a larger
organization so hopefully like the tool
I'll show you in a second will will help
with both both of those things um but uh
first of all like it it's good to start
with um answering the question what is
great design because design is a very
general word many people uh have
different ideas about what it means
exactly so the first thing is to clarify
what do what do we mean by grade design
in our
context so first of all our assumption
is that grade design makes apps useful
for a particular type of person for a
particular application solving an
important problem for them in their
particular context so number one trade
or resol of gr design is
usefulness number two that gr design
makes apps easy to use so it's it's not
enough that it technically solves some
kind of problem it uh it helps if it's
easy to use if it doesn't provide or put
put unnecessary obstacles in the path of
the users so number two easy to use and
number three beautiful so as I said it's
not the most important thing it's not
the only thing uh when it comes to
design but of course it is one of the
factors and one reason is that well
there there is a bias that beauty equals
virtue so if it's beautiful I could get
judge better regardless um and of course
uh we we want our users to be happy
about using the app and we want to be
proud
about that for the apps that we create
so so that's also a
factor okay and one thing I wanted to
underline that those are some high level
aspirations but uh in practice uh we are
not expecting that everyone will will
hit Perfection every time so it's enough
to use the tool to make things better to
make the app a little more useful a
little easier to use a little more
beautiful and that's already start of a
success it doesn't have to be perfect
from the
start okay so let me give you a quick
example of how we used this framework in
a recent project that we had so we we
built an up for Boston Medical Center it
took about two months um
it's called the Health Equity Explorer
it
helps doctors and researchers analyze
data about population Health to
hopefully discover systematic factors
that lead to good or bad Health outcomes
for for a whole population or or area um
and uh so one thing we tried to put a
lot of effort intoing it useful and we
did it through like close collaboration
with the client we talked almost every
day to make sure that we will understand
their needs that we understand their
context and that this app really fits
fits those things and second we try to
make it easy to use and uh of course the
the key tool to to make it easy to use
is user testing so as Maria told you a
few minutes ago it's about having the
user attempt to perform uh their task in
the app and then without too much
explanation without leading being led by
the hand and then we can see are they
successful are they not where do they
get stuck and so on and then then we can
go from there so we did a lot of user
testing for this app and then in the end
of course we tried to add some spit and
polish to make it a little
nicer to look at so that was a quick
example of of how how and a framework
like that can can be applied so uh the
question is like okay great design nice
story but uh so who who should be
involved like one thing a great design
so maybe the designers are responsible
for design and of course designers
should be involved uh but it's not only
designers like uh other people need to
be involved in the whole process to to
achieve that goal like also managers
project leaders Engineers on the team
and maybe most importantly the clients
themselves so design is not only about
beauty and design is also not only about
designers so uh how do you make it
happen well now now I'll show you so we
have several tools that help us do that
but today I will show you one and this
one is a our design planning and
evaluation tool uh it's a humble uh
Google sheet uh with some sections and
so now I will walk you through the
various sections don't worry about
reading the details later I will give
you a link and you can download it for
yourself and uh learn more and hopefully
adapt it or use it for for your your
projects as well so there are four
sections one is like general information
section client up name the history of
our involvement uh because maybe we are
taking over an app or maybe we build it
from scratch or maybe even we are
evaluating an existing app that we
didn't even make just to to learn about
about stuff so so that's the first part
and then there are three parts uh
relating to the three traits of great
design so blue section usefulness green
section easy to use red section
beautiful so zooming in on the
usefulness section uh one one key thing
is that we separate planning and
evaluation so at first we
started with the evaluation part but
quickly found out that if we evaluate a
project at the end of course that's too
late to change anything about it so
definitely we have to plan for for to
achieve great design up front and then
then then that's uh like at the end
valuation will be better so one one
thing there's a section to just answer
the question like who is it for what is
the target audience what kind of users
uh will use the app of course it's not
enough to just say users um and what
problem are we solving for them uh and
then we have sections for the things
that that really really want to achieve
which is adoption how many people are
you will be using the app how often over
what time and uh what impact is it going
to make so for adoption it helps to ask
up front Okay how are we going to
measure it like just putting in the
instrumentation to measure adoption is
already not obvious in some situations
so how how are we going to measure it
and then also like what what uh what
would be a successful number like what
are we expecting to achieve and then
let's say after after a few months let's
say we have 10 users is that a success
or not success well it depends on what
kind of users what problem they are
solving sometimes one user using the up
once can be a success if it's like I
don't know they show it to some Senator
and they then pass some law based on the
that they are convinced based on on the
app so maybe that would be a success
even though if it's just one
user um so it's good to have those
conversations up front and uh also an
important conversation that that is good
to have at the start is that to imagine
like okay we've shipped the we are
talking about some up the client maybe
lists some functions that they expect in
the app but then it's important to ask
okay so let's imagine we ship the app
all the functions are there and what
will happen
then a very simple question but uh it
helps to uncover maybe gaps in our
thinking that uh uh maybe to achieve the
goal that they have in mind maybe not
all of those functionalities are
necessary or maybe we need to do
something extra maybe we need to do some
training maybe we need to do a video
explaining the app to people or maybe we
just need to collect email addresses
before we ship the app
um there are many things in the general
area of let's say product management
that we can do uh to to achieve this
bigger impact regardless of the shape of
the app so that's uh uh this going
through this section in the sheet helps
teams to to have those important
conversations and to explain with
clients like why are we asking those
questions and uh and in what context do
we see it so that was the usefulness
section uh ease of use section includes
some various methods and that's the
general shape of the tool that in each
section we collect various methods that
we are experimenting with and over time
like we can have conversations it's not
mandatory to use all the methods for all
the projects but it contains options to
consider so uh for example the the main
two things that that we have in the EAS
of use section is of course user testing
so that's the same thing that Mario was
talking about with prototyping and quick
prot protyping showing users and the
most important thing is that we we don't
want to explain it to users and ask what
they think we want to see them use it
with minimum explanation and then talk
about it so that's that's the gold
standard user testing for us but of
course there there are also other ways
so we like to use this list of 10
usability her istics by yob nilon that's
an article that summarizes how to make
apps that are easy to use now um and so
for example this is this is an example
of a filled in evaluation for one of our
apps with those yakob newsense hor
istics so as you can see we did a good
job on visibility of system status but
maybe not necessarily error prevention
so that would be a signal to maybe in
the next iteration we should think about
error
handling um and finally the beauty part
uh so yeah of course beauty is to some
extent sub objective but the opinion of
like specific people is already a fact
uh so we can work with that we can have
also expert feedback or also hortic
evaluation using a slightly different
set of hortic evaluations just for
Aesthetics not usability and uh finally
we we had good experience with a ebook
called refactoring UI which contains a
lot of design tips that is specifically
tailored to for developers to use so if
we don't have like a professional
designer involved it helps to use
refactoring UI and go through just tips
um that are there and you can get
surprisingly far that
way yeah so those are our methods for
for making the app beautiful yeah and uh
also that's uh if you haven't seen
Mario's talk maybe you can catch it
online later uh about the power of
prototyping that also helps in this
context
okay so I showed you a lightning review
of of our this form that that teams can
fill in but you might be asking yourself
but is anyone actually going to use it
if we just send by email to all the
teams oh here's a new form to fill
please use it that that will probably
not be effective and you'll probably be
right that we are not expecting to just
for people to just use it automatically
but we are treating this tool itself uh
with the same framework that we propose
for apps so we we try to understand the
needs of of the various teams of
Engineers clients uh leaders um involved
in those projects we test it with users
and improve so this sheet that you are
seeing today is actually the third
iteration and hopefully there will be
more iterations after
that so and like we are using it also
like talking about this tool it's also a
form of education so of course we don't
expect people to just understand and do
everything perfectly themselves rather
um rather we U work with them like in
let's say interactive way so uh with
that in mind like we had uh in in the
past few months we had nine practice
applications of of this approach and
here are the some some benefits that
that popped up again and again so one
benefit is that this kind of approach
helps us identify problems that can lead
to bad user experience um that we might
otherwise miss it it helps you like zoom
out look at the broader context but also
go through in a systematic way through
various things that uh even if you are
an experienc developer if even if you
are an experience designer you might not
think about every time so it's like a
checklist for that second thing is it
can help find low hanging fruits so uh
sometimes like it takes the same effort
to do it well compared to doing it
poorly if only we know like what we
should do so so it can if we do this
evaluation early in the planning phase
uh or or evaluate an early prototype we
can find things that we can just
automatically do better without
additional
investment and number three and maybe
most importantly it helps improve the
quality of conversations that we have
around design uh within the team and
with clients to to create a shared
understanding of what we mean by various
things like great design like usefulness
and so on uh and it also helps people to
just learn about about the topic if
they're interested
in so to summarize how to make apps
users love well first of all uh think
about more than just Beauty number one
usefulness number two usability making
it easy to use and finally
beautiful and uh it helps to talk about
it to plan it to be deliberate about
this planning and fin finally to
evaluate your progress so you can do it
better next time and most of all just
care about
it so if you care about it uh you can uh
download the slides from this QR code
and this link go. ups.com design and uh
you can talk to me at the booth although
the booth is disappearing soon I here
but you can find me in the hallway and
if not you can find me
online yeah so thank
you thank you so I'm peeking at slider
for the questions and uh one of them is
how do you avoid over engineering
apps that's a problem but one way is to
do like we uh with we do that we think
about usefulness so that automatically
focuses our attention like what do we
need to achieve this purpose and then we
do user testing and with early
prototypes which also shows like are we
on the right track or not and we do it
in short iterations closely with the
client so may maybe it happens sometimes
but that's how we reduce this
risk um the other question we have is
can you talk a bit about getting Buy in
from clients or users um around design
decisions about specific design
decisions or decisions in general or
design
decisions but I guess it extends I guess
you know the that that's going to so so
we frame the conversation about like
what are trying to achieve adoption and
impact so if uh some design decision
like can be viewed in this um light then
then it will be easy to convince people
like do you want like if they believe
that we are actually addressing what
they really want uh then it will be
easier to convince it's not just
designed for Design's
sake thank you
okay I think we're making like a a
landing on the spot for the coffee um no
there's not just some slider question
just hitting me unexpected okay great so
um I would love for you to join me in
thanking all of our speakers again so
thank you very
[Applause]
much